Western blot is a technique to detect
and analyze the protein of Interest it
is based on the principle of antigen
antibody interaction in the first step
the gel is ran where the protein is
basically separated on base of its
molecular weight so among these protein
present in the gel we need to find
whether our protein of interest is
present or not and that is detected
using an antibody but first the content
of the gel that means all the proteins
are basically transferred into a pvdf
membrane with Electro blotting technique
then the membrane is incubated with
primary antibody blocking solution and
then the secondary antibody let's say
the protein of interest is present so
the primary antibody would detect that
protein of Interest secondary board
antibody would detect the primary
antibody and a color reaction would be
developed
there are different modes of development
like enzymatic chemiluminescent and
fluorescent this is how a typical gel
look like and there are wide variety of
applications of Western